welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled
lateral flow assay development from
lab-based assay to diagnostics test
prototype
introducing sativa's development
services platform
it's my pleasure to introduce you to lee
jenkins
senior product leader saitiva for a
complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen if any questions arise during the
presentation
we encourage you to submit them via the
q a box
and our speaker will address your
questions at the end of the presentation
please join me in welcoming lee jenkins
i will now turn the presentation over to
him
okay hi so thank you for introduction so
as
introduced i'm lee jenkins and i'm here
to take you through
accelerating development and a focus on
saitvs development services platform
so the presentation today is going to go
through
these agenda points so i'll start off
with a overview
of the common development challenges
i'll move into
a overdue decibel diagnostic services
covering what it includes and how we
overcome development challenges
i'll go into a typical custom
development process
and close with a case studies and
a quick q a so if you've got any
questions throughout the presentation
please feel free to come into the chat
and i'll pick them up
at the end of the call so uh going into
a overview of the common development
challenges
so you can see on this slide that we've
outlined
six different concepts which we've had
feedback
typical challenges for developers going
through a new product
launch i'll spend a couple of minutes
going through each one
talking about why it's important to
yourselves going through the process you
know what the constraints are
things you need to be aware of but also
you know a little hint
on how they can be overcome and what we
can help
to provide uh within the service
so starting on the first aspect which is
the access to experienced scientists
so one of the things about latter flows
which attracts people to developing
them as a product concept is that they
are pretty much
unrivaled among other types of rapid
tests when it comes to the speed and
ease of use
the fact that it can be used by people
away from central labs they can be used
at a point of care
or they can be using a home-based
sentence however
the ease of use can quite easily you
know give a little bit
of a complex development because
it's quite a highly informed
decision-making process you need to
have careful consideration of different
elements of the test including the
cellos the parts and other key
components
and it's quite easy to underestimate
that so access to a key
scientist who has done this before can
really help accelerate your development
at this stage
you also have the aspect of you know
someone who has produced these tests
before
uh they were aware of the the common
risks and
the setbacks their experiences taught
them from previously
you know it helps them to speed up the
iterative
assay design process and it can lead to
a more optimal solution
that's you know saves your hunt to
repeat testing or repeat development at
a later stage
the third point is that you know
experienced staff also have knowledge of
what works
and that can be quite key because when
you're developing a new platform
you know you have to start from complete
scratch but you might have
a scientist who knows you know what
detection particles work well with what
membranes and what parts for example and
it can significantly reduce your
development time as a result
so all of these are key to making sure
that you know you've been through your
development process as smooth as
possible
okay so the next part i'm going to take
you into is robustness of design
so under robustness of design you know
talking about the complexity in the
previous slide
it's very important that you manage that
complexity and that you've got a working
product at the end of it that
is substantially developed in order to
quantum market as it's intended to so
you need to be able to understand issues
from lay person use so you're not going
to have clinicians in all instances
using these tests
so it has to be error proof in some
respects
it has to be able to work in different
humilities and
temperatures and it has to have a good
stability over time because
you want to have your product on the
shelf for you know
the longer term as possible they also
need to be developed
and this one's quite important using the
full breadth of the product
specification
so typically doing development now it's
important that you get
products from the extremes of a
specification
so you'll have a product with a
nominal or an average rating but within
the
typical release it might vary and you
need to test that so
make sure you understand any variation
stack within
your product so you don't want the
product to fall over
once it's in the field or the later
stage as a result of
you know not enough rigorous testing and
it's important that you consider all
these aspects during the design process
the third part is you know the world
we're all working in with regards to the
latter flow test is typically a medical
device
framework we all work into iso 13.5 and
as much as possible you need to ensure
that everybody throughout your process
is working to the same standard
so if you can have someone further down
your protest your development partners
or your component suppliers who are
qualified to the same standard
it can significantly you know reassure
your risk process
you know you've got quality products but
also it can help with audits
trails and traceability of design
history files at the later stage
okay the next framework which we're
going to touch on
is the rapid prototyping of designs
and you know this is something again
which as you go through the process
it's important that you're able to test
your ideas
that you're able to work out how
successful your design is going to be as
early as possible in the process before
you start investing
large amounts of time of resource of you
know of money in this process
so rapidly getting from that idea to a
proof of principle or proof of concept
despite
of you know proving your idea to whether
it's your stakeholders whether it's your
investors
you know whatever it is that's going to
trigger that next milestone of
investment in the project
again key considerations here that how
do you work with different design
formulations
in parallel to avoid time and delays in
the process
how to optimize the test conditions so
that they're repeatable and that you
don't get
again variation later in your process
how do you overcome
and evaluate commercial viability in a
simple low-cost way
and how do you access equipment and
skills needed to quickly
develop prototypes you know in
development stage you might
have a competing priorities between
trying to achieve
all of these things but at the same time
you know you don't want to
invest in expensive equipment or you
don't want to hire
scientists when you can't give a
long-term commitment to
how long they're going to be you know
required by your project
so being able to get rapid prototyping
and quickly prove your
concepts is a key part of the moment
the next one is access to funding so i
touched on
on it a little bit in the last slide how
rapid prototyping quickly can help you
access funding but
you know it's key in any development
trying to prove as early as possible in
your project
the pro the concept is valuable
it's you know it releases the next phase
of funding but also it reinforces your
resources you do have you make sure you
spend them in the right places
and this can give you challenges and
competent priorities because
there's that type of how do you manage
budget constraints against the needs for
proven design and generating prototypes
at the same time
you know one potential way around this
is to look at the development and bursts
where you can outsource trenches of work
you need up front so that
you know a simple way of freeing up that
investment
without having to over commit or process
resources because you get a very
precise package of work delivered okay
so two more points i've gotten here the
next one
is about access to infrastructure and
you can see in the image on the slide
a large bio dot reel-to-reel dispenser
and the key part around this is that
making sure that when you're in your
r d process it's key to get access to a
working fully kitted out diagnostic lab
because one of the critical challenges
is making sure you go
from a lab skill test or just a bench
top
you know simple test that you've
developed yourself but then making sure
it's replicable
on a large industrial scale everybody
wants that test which is going to
produce you know millions of
uh sales and you have to have a way of
being able to produce your product on
the same scale
in order to achieve those sales so the
going back to the funding and the
infrastructure elements
now there's obviously a consideration of
how would you handle this can you
purchase can you lease equipment
can you get access to a lab which if you
access all this equipment in a timely
way at a low expense
it's going back to the you know being
able to prove your concept in a very
risk
very timely ways that you can move on
with your project and get through your
milestones as quick as possible and then
probably the most important one last of
all is protection of ip
so now we've gotten a slide that your ip
is precious and the life budget
life blood your business and that can't
be underestimated
now ip is everything to new startups and
been able to protect that design did
everything
you got to make sure that everybody
you're working with the process at all
steps that you're holding onto lip that
there's no
loss or unnecessary sharing so
choosing a partner or choosing the right
way to work on your
concept you know there's important
considerations that you get that back at
the end of the process
so that's why i'm going to go into the
next part of the presentation
is going from you know these six
concepts
taking you through a process we actually
sativa we're trying to support you we'll
partner with companies to
go from an idea to a point of care test
so the comments
on here is you know i have a lab based
test that could be optimized into a
commercially available particular test
but people don't know how to do that or
they don't know with turn for advice
or for support we have the service which
can help provide the path from an idea
or a lab-based test to the approved
rapid diagnostic test
and you know looking at development the
challenges the frustrations the hurdles
we can work with you to overcome that in
a simple way we can use our experience
our infrastructure
the components we have and the scale of
sativa to help you know get people
through this process in a very quick and
timely way
so as i mentioned our service is titled
sativa diagnostic services and
essentially it's a way for people to
navigate between
the development process so it covers
everything from networking
collaboration and transparency
you can see on this slide we have
essentially the series built up
it's two pillars on the left hand side
then there's two things on the right
which
going back to those considerations from
earlier a key for everybody
so the services first of all is looking
at
training and education so for people who
have this idea or they have a biomarker
or they are their laser test but they've
never built a latch or flow
one of the key elements we can offer is
training for people to help teach them
the basics of the process
we can get them started on introduction
to lots
of flow teaching typical
pitfalls and issues which you need to
avoid so that they can
make sure that the project was smooth
and this can either be in a classroom
a on-site or online education so we
understand that
now with the current uh pandemic
situation that
maybe classroom or face-to-face isn't
possible for everybody at the moment
so we could use virtual approaches or
alternatively you know we're happy to
invite people
we say to do so to come to our
our lab in germany and we have a
hands-on classroom session
the sessions can be tailored around
anything you want to know so typically
it'd be
you know a couple of day session up to
maybe four or five days
where we can look through processes so
teaching dispensing protocols teach you
how to use a vehicle for
spr analysis to select your detection
pairs
whether it's looking to use dispensers
whether it's looking to
do your component selection so which
membranes to choose what pulse
choose how to make sure that everything
fits together how to get rid of
any non-specific binding you know we can
do all of this within the framework
you know and the last but for the point
is looking at workshops
so if you just have a challenge with
something you want help coaching to
overcome
you can use our expertise to help coach
you through that can be a hands-on
in-depth session where you know we can
set you up so that you're ready for the
future and you know what to do next time
this issue appears
the second element of the service is the
development expertise
so again you know several different
forms this could take so it could be
methods development so we can help with
you to create
sops or to create you know this bring us
rigor to your process which was
mentioned earlier
we can look at methods transfer so we
can help you go between
a development size product
into a manufacturing site project or we
can even help transfer you into a
contract manufacturing organization
there is methods qualification so we can
help you with your validation and
verification of your designs
or it can be shorter you know little
informal bits of work look at
troubleshooting so
if you've got non-specific binding or if
you've got a low sensitivity or
accuracy test you can help optimize that
and then finally you know it's
outsourcing of development so this is
looking at the whole
wing-to-wing in the process so taking it
from that very early stage
right the way through to a working
manufacturing skill test which we hang
back to
you know obviously a lot more
comprehensive work
but again all in partnership and all in
open transparency of working together
throughout the process
the other two parts we bring the iep
protection and transparency
so you know we're happy to share
everything we're doing it's a discussion
it's a collaboration
and we can talk through step by step
what's next in the process
you know in agreement on how we perceive
that each part of the process
if you're able to access the site we can
give
full access to see what we do and work
together during development
or if it's virtual we can you know
provide all the protocols electronically
and have regular future calls
but the important part of this is that
you know what i tested on earlier about
vip being
survivor all of the ap transfers back to
the original owner at saitva we don't
know
any of this you know you have everything
back there's no licensing
and it's a clean handbag of everything
to do with that i say
materials and infrastructure so you know
you've seen a few
images throughout the presentation where
we have this working lab
but you know we can use our equipment
and our processes
our staff to do everything from
stability trials
a lot of release testing complete
management so if you've got some
complaints and you can't work through
what's going wrong in the test we can
help with that or even more material
inspection
and i've been incoming and outgoing qt
tests
okay so to move on for that you know
this is covering a typical
customization process and development
process and how we can work together
so you know product concept is
a very early stage idea of what you want
to achieve
going through to a custom design you
know if it's working with us
you can look at customization of
membranes or pads
we can help work with any bespoke
designs you want whether it's a
unique cartridge or a unique lateral
flow test
going across optimization and validation
so we can help with you know small scale
prototypes and then
take it out onto a larger scale
manufacturing so once you get your
product
through and onto the market we will
support you from that stage
and then obviously ongoing support so
touching on this you know once you're in
the field
what you need is it a regular supplier
product or
if you have any sort of performance
issues we can help coach you for that as
well
so that's the presentation i have i'm
gonna
just run a short video to conclude the
session
and then i'll jump back on to take any
questions from the q a
so people feel free to put anything in
the chat and i'll come back to you and
speak to you shortly
thanks everybody
my name is i am the ceo of a
biotech startup that is called futano
diagnostics we are developing a disease
diagnostic and surveillance platform
where you put blood on the diagnostic
and in 10 minutes it tells you if the
patient has a ball or not
and then it sends a message to an online
platform and tells us where the patient
is located
and then predicts where the disease will
spread for the past three days we have
been doing a diagnostic development
workshop in dassler
our experience with the coaching
workshop has been truly
educational it is rare
to be able to speak about the science
the production and the business in one
conversation without a post
because we have a conversation that
moves from
the technical bits to the manufacturing
to the business to the intellectual
property
something that is rare to find in the
past three to four years that we've been
speaking to people about the work that
we do
being a lean starter means that we don't
have
a lot of the infrastructure and
equipment that is present at this
facility
but being able to work with the
equipment and the facility
has helped us to see what we can grow to
become
and to envision what our later stage rnd
and scaling up will look like my name is
charlotte masorum
i am the principal scientist at
retirement diagnostics
this experience has allowed us to
gain a better perspective for where we
want to
be and what it takes to get there it has
allowed us to
forecast potential challenges along the
way
and has allowed us to refine and
redefine our
research and development strategy and so
the different challenges we have been
addressing have been
on simplifying the interaction between
our diagnostic and the patient and
improving the impact of that
for the next 18 months we will
definitely change our course
the work that we've been doing here has
helped us to reshape our r d strategy
and to become more efficient okay so the
next step is
getting back to oxford getting into the
lab and continuing with our with our r d
and continuing to refine our product
development pathway
and make our product at a much more
efficient pace
because the lessons that we've been
getting in this
workshop have saved us months of
development
so i would definitely recommend that
other companies enter this competition
program has allowed us to be able to
have a
fuller more broader perspective of
r d to manufacturing to distribution
and beyond to to the end user
thank you lee for that outstanding
presentation we will now move into the
live q a portion of the presentation
as a reminder please submit your
question via the q a box
so our first question is can you give an
example of the type of tissue this
service can help with
okay thank you so the example
of the time we work with previously is
just um
we had one company who approached us to
help with troubleshooting of the
assay so
the market but they were getting us with
uh accuracy of their results in the
field
so we helped them identify what the root
cause was
um specifically in this case that during
development they only tested components
from the middle of the specification
ranges
across several items and then as the
product went
into the field there was issues with one
of the
items still being in specification but
being slightly away from the
normal center of the range and then this
call
was some variation they would have gone
to the accuracy
so after helping identify the root cause
we could very quickly have to resolve
the problem
so um i think this is a perfect example
of what we
other examples are like the hutano
diagnostics video
you know as a customer we we
specifically took them
from an idea into the feasibility of the
content
great okay i've got another question for
you
will saitima own the ip of any element
of the test post development
and now so hopefully i try to touch on
this as part of the presentation but
this question came in early no so cyto
sativa as a company we try to be as
transparent as possible
so we make sure that all the agreements
up front um specify this but
we want all of the ip back to the
diagnostic developer
now we are not a diagnostic company our
interest in this is helping our
customers get to the market as quick as
possible
so the only iep we maintain is around
manufacture
and supply of our components otherwise
everything else goes back to
the excuse me for the regulatory filing
of the test
okay thank you third question
will sativa be able to help with the
manufacture of my test post development
so hopefully the person asking us in the
session
earlier with john from underdone health
who were talking about
um contract manufacturing organizations
so at sativa you know we can't help with
the actual manufacture of the test
normally um you know encourage you to
get in contact with us to discuss this
but what we can't do is help with the
process of transferring
into a contract manufacturer so we can
help you go through
the process to make sure that everything
is developed that you have all the
correct protocols that you have
identified a cmo to work with
and then we can help you you know doing
that process
if anyone wants any more advice or
conversation around this encourage them
to get in contact or we can discuss on a
case-by-case basis
okay our next question
is the service only available in europe
or is it worldwide
so it's worldwide so the resources for
this are currently based
in germany so in our manufacturing site
in dussel which is where we produce our
membranes
such as the nitrocellulose going into
blood products
but it's yes worldwide so at present
we have the germany base we are looking
into expanding into a china base for
2021
um albeit will be on a smaller scale but
yeah open to work with any customers
across all regions
great thank you lee um next question
does sativa have loyalty to any specific
reagent supplier as part of their
development
so two points i didn't know
so we have suppliers we work with and
generally based upon
what we feel about a quality product and
people we know with stable supply chains
and products
early available but if a customer has
any specific requirements
we can discuss this with them so if they
have a particular supplier they
use in their test or people who don't
want to use
obviously we're happy to consider us at
the scope of the project
the best approach for this would be for
the customer to again get in contact
with us and
we can talk details about what they want
and understand
you know what their requirements are
okay got another question does this
service have to be performed at the
saitiva site
or can it take place at the customer
site
interesting question because given the
pandemic it's a slightly different slant
on this question i guess the normal so
before
the whole world change due to the
covert 19 and the current endemic we
were looking to
take this as a series that we could
visit the sites
um honestly they would have to have a
diagnostic job and
able to have the resources to host the
sort of work involved
but we would also encourage people to
come visit us
in germany but um the change and how
we're working now is that
obviously we're not traveling as much
and people aren't coming over to us
so we're working a lot more digitally
and by electronic means so a lot more
video calls up more skype
and teams calls so you know
happy to talk with a customer on what
works best
best for them but it'd be digital in the
future it could be either approached
and on what they have available if they
come to germany
it obviously allows us to show the site
and to
understand manufacturing around the need
to sell those products etc
but um yeah case by case i'll be
discussing
what works best for them okay
thank you lee our next question
are you looking at developing covid19
antigen lateral flow test
in the presentation that um we don't
know about our own tests
you know when we talk about ip and about
customers this is all about taking
the projects and helping them get into
the market quicker
so we're not developing our own
cooperating
but we do have some active projects we
are working on which are
trying to do so so we've had some press
releases previously
um if there was probably people on the
internet with a little around
but um yes there was a project we're
working on and
we're open to discussing anything that
people want to work with us on
okay our next question what is the
general timeline and cost from product
concept
stage to manufacturing scale
so this question is very dependent on
what the customer is trying to achieve
so what the test is um you know how many
targets whether it's a single or
multiplexing
um what stage for the concept they're at
so it is awkward to give a direct answer
to this on the forum
probably you know the best way would be
for us to contact the customer
around this event we can discuss you
know directly what they're trying to
achieve
but timelines you know a typical
diagnostic test
you would traditionally be looking two
to three years to go through a whole
development
get through trials gets around the
market around
covered 19 we've been forced to look at
a lot
shorter too so we typically looking more
than six months
for the development and that's put a lot
more urgency and pressure on the
timelines
but um yeah you know encourage the
customer we can talk to them
basically about what they're doing
understand their tests and then
a specific quote on whatever cost and
the timelines involved
okay looks like we have one more
question here
what are some of the factors that need
to be considered while transferring the
manufacturing process from one facility
to another
so again i mentioned earlier that
there's a presentation
earlier today from african health this
was specifically what
the topic was about so i can summarize
quickly but
john spent you know like a q a
in depth in this topic so i think this
look at that more details
so essentially it's all about ensuring
that the
test has the correct level of stability
so that
you know it can go from a bench top
scale
and your conjugates once they drive
they're able to withstand
they're transferred to a larger
manufacturing process that
you have a robust design so that it's
all transferable and that they worked
and handled
well it looks like he may have frozen up
lee
can you still hear us
okay well it looks like we've lost lee's
video so
um any questions that are submitted in
the on-demand period can be answered
by the speaker via email thank you again
lee and thank you to the audience for
your outstanding questions
this presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing for 12 months
please remember to share it with your
colleagues who might be interested in
today's topic
and don't miss out on the other
presentations on our agenda
visit the agenda tab in the auditorium
for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
and until next time goodbye